oh wow Oh Moxley geez I woke up today
and I was told that it's not a joke and
you're gonna break my jaw I've seen the
tough-guy act and you pull it off quite
well so nobody mean never for real yeah
we did would you would you hear from no
wonder he didn't give me a sec yeah one
sec no biggie Steve I'm miked up
let's just let's kill the lights cuz
let's talk about this Wes look we might
as well talk about it you know what
wow what a sad story right don't you
don't you feel sorry for Jon Moxley I
mean he he just showed up he defied he
defied the wrestling God and he came to
aw threw me off the stack of chips and
anyone in this journey a warrior's
journey he wanted to know what it was
like to live a month in the life of
Kenny Omegas shoes insert wrestler name
here better than sign kenny omega and
people are doing that with you they were
they work because you were like the hot
topic for 15 minutes this is your big
chance of redemption in the excitement
of being a free man
you called it a paradigm shift right now
that was cool like you're going to shirt
and then you went to Japan how did that
turn him and go in Japan
did you win I know that I did first try
got the shirt to prove it you decided to
start wanting to check off all those
boxes on that bucket list of yours did
anyone really talk about you in Japan
you got a boo-boo on your elbow what's
your explanation
but we get you just kidding you're gonna
write up a sappy a sappy tweet
apologizing to everyone make everyone
feel bad for you Kenny what happened to
the dream match Kenny what happened to
jon moxley what happened when sri did i
go to japan and wrestle 24 days of the
month before fighting you know you see I
did this thing John it's called being a
professional what am I supposed to say I
was ready I took you seriously I never
got myself injured I got myself in the
best shape of my life he never took me
seriously you never took this
pay-per-view seriously you owe everyone
an apology you owe me an apology and you
should really look in the mirror John
mm-hmm you should look in the mirror and
you should ask yourself the [ __ ] am i
doing I'm playing this all back in my
mind and I'm thinking oh [ __ ]
oh boy I'm being really insensitive cuz
this is this is a real serious injury
you could have happened to anybody right
you are careless I blame you and if
people want to look at me like I'm the
bad guy
she's just as bad as you are John he
left a lot of pieces a lot of broken
dreams and a lot of disappointed fans
laid upon my feet and they're begging
for something now
what kind of wrestler does that
okay well I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
beat up the best wrestler in the world
check IIIi want to go to Japan now check
can I do some Indies check can you a
hardcore match check see John I
I would love to wish you a speedy
recovery that's what I'm supposed to say
but at this point I could really give a
[ __ ] if you ever come back